So I'll try to provide an overview and considering the time limitations, I'll just really highlight
some of the data that came from ASH this year and also kind of the areas that we need a
lot of improvement on.
I shared the excitement that my myeloma colleagues had this morning.
We have a lot more work to do, I think, in diffuse large B-cell lymphoma.
So this is the current paradigm for treatment and management of diffuse large B-cell lymphoma.
This is adapted from the NCCN guidelines.
In the frontline setting, the anthracycline-based therapies have an established role in the
more recent data set that was updated with Polarix's five-year follow-up, establishing
improved efficacy in favor of a polituzumab anthracycline-based backbone.
And you can see on the left upper-hand side, the panel there, the curves still persist.
So the responses continue to persist.
And on the right-hand side in the panel, you can see...
Even though the cell lymphomas are still present, the response continues to persist.
The study didn't have an overall survival benefit.
There is an advantage to the progression-free survival in the sense that a lot of the patients
require less subsequent lines of therapy in terms of systemic therapy, transplant, CAR-T
cells, or radiotherapy.
And this was a very, very tolerable regimen, and most patients can complete their therapy.
Now, what else is remaining in the frontline setting?
Obviously, we're not curing everybody.
So part of the problem still remains increasing response.
And increasing durable responses and cures in the frontline setting.
And specifically, who am I talking about?
Patients that have high-risk IPI and molecularly high-risk disease, double hits, triple hits,
those kinds of things.
And so in this context, there is some thought of incorporating, obviously, new agents, including
bispecifics in frontline, as well as including other targeted agents like BTK inhibitors in
the frontline.
Some of the newer data, and this is what I'm highlighting here.
There is, regarding autologous CAR-T-cells, CD19-directed CAR-T-cells, there were a number
of abstracts in this regard.
And this is a representative one.
This is RAP-captogen, a CD19-directed CAR.
This study was for frontline treatment of patients.
And on the bottom left-hand corner of the screen, you can see this is majority of the
patients have high risk by IPI.
In the middle column there, you can see with frontline use, overall response rate here
was 90%, with 74% of these patients achieving a complete response.
So at least in this context, we are able to control the disease.
This is a short-term, the follow-up was relatively short on this study.
So at least in the context of this presentation, the median duration of response was not reached.
At six months, about 80% of the patients still remain.
Free of disease.
And so at least it lends itself to the possibility that we can use this strategy in frontline
for high-risk patients.
The other thing to think about is, does everybody really need aggressive cytotoxic chemotherapy?
There were, as a study done in 2019, this has been publicized with mosonatuzumab in elderly
patients that are ineligible for anthracycline-based therapy.
And in that category of patients, we have a lot of patients who are ineligible for anthracycline-based
therapy.
And in that category of patients, about 30% of the patients actually remained free of
disease with just frontline bispecific therapy.
This is, they never got any chemotherapy, any sort of cytotoxic.
So that's the old data.
And this is from a separate study Jeff Sharman presented this year at ASH, reflecting essentially
the same thing.
The Morning Sun study was a large study, and they reported a DLBC health cohort here for
elderly patients that are...
Or patients that have comorbidities that are ineligible.
And on the bottom left-hand side, you can see the overall response rate here, again,
with single-agent mosonatuzumab with large-cell lymphoma, overall response rate is around
70%.
Majority of that tends to be a CR.
And again, with a very short follow-up on the bottom right-hand side, you can see there
are...
This is extremely short follow-up.
So I think the majority of the data in this regard would come from older studies and observing
these patients.
I think the majority of the data is from older studies and observing these patients for a
long term.
But it proves the point that potentially some patients may not need cytotoxic chemotherapy
for treatment of their diffuse large B-cell lymphoma, especially in the context of these
previously untreated patients that actually have an intact immune system.
This is a similar study with epcortimab, same patient population, but I highlighted there
at the bottom middle panel there, on this particular study, again, same strategy of
epcortimab, a CD20 bispecific as single-agent.
This study actually evaluated MRD, and you can see in the bottom middle column there
with single-agent epcortimab, you can actually achieve MRD negativity and sustain it.
Again, a very short follow-up requires longer follow-up, but same concept can be re-emphasized.
Now, in the relapsed refractory setting, we have quite a number of options in terms of
CAR-T-cells bispecific.
So, you can see that there are two combinations, and polituzumab combinations, and the same thing
applies in the third-line setting.
I'll highlight the SunMo data.
This was a randomized study, randomized morsonituzumab plus polituzumab versus RGEM-MOX.
On the bottom left-hand side, you can see, actually, the tolerability of the regimen,
very well tolerated with a very manageable CRS, and on the right-hand side, you can see
there is a definition of RGEM-MOX.
So, you can see that there is a definition of RGEM-MOX, and on the right-hand side, you can see there is a definition of RGEM-MOX.
So, you can see that there is a definition of RGEM-MOX.